el tiempo será de como
[Aplausos]
minutos más tarde despega el único avión
de aero sarayaku
la aerolínea de los pueblos kichwa
sarayaku de ecuador
en el horizonte una selva llena de
riquezas que los indígenas defienden a
diario de la llegada de actores
exteriores
luego de 30 minutos de vuelo aterricé
entre las riberas del río bobonaza
[Música]
aquí dirijo sé el líder comunitario que
impulsó la creación de aero sarayaku
luchó para impedir la incursión de una
empresa petrolera argentina que
pretendió explotar su territorio sin
consultarles ganando una demanda frente
a las cortes internacionales
con un fondo de indemnización que fue
dictaminado por la corte interamericana
de derechos humanos en un juicio que
seguimos por violación de derechos al
pueblo de sarayaku
y donde recibimos
un millón de dólares casi el
40% ha sido invertido en esta empresa
con el dictamen favorable la asamblea
del pueblo autorizó la creación de aero
sarayaku impedir la construcción de
carreteras que facilitarán la llegada de
actores exteriores permitió a los
aldeanos controlar el desarrollo de sus
tierras
nos preocupa la expansión agresiva de
las carreteras
qué es un fenómeno invisible que
funciona a través de políticas de estado
a través de gobiernos locales
la administración del estado
en complicidad con
grandes corporaciones petroleras
están introduciendo ampliando las
fronteras petroleras que amenazan el
ecosistema la biodiversidad el bosque la
vida de las comunidades
porque entre comillas lo proponen que es
un desarrollo pero en realidad
nos están matando
es esta lucha la que motiva nuevos
aspirantes indígenas a formarse como
pilotos estaba cursando para pilotos
he culminado los
los honrados teóricos y prácticos y por
cuestiones de recursos financieros casi
o sea me quedo ahí en esta etapa de el
estudio
en esta región de bravos caudales una
aerolínea no podría funcionar sin el
apoyo de una canoa gerardo gualinga
dirige las operaciones marítimas que
benefician a hero sarayaku conectan las
230 pistas de aterrizaje que comunican
el territorio de su pueblo con las
comunidades y en caso de mal tiempo la
canoa vuelve a ser el transporte
principal
para cualquier emergencia que pueda
entonces nos comunicamos rápidamente
entonces coordinamos si el tiempo está
operable aquí entonces la avioneta viene
y sino nosotros tenemos que evacuar por
el río esto demora si el río está así
esto puede durar cuatro horas si el
ruido está bastante crecido hacemos dos
horas y media
hoy puede sentirse orgulloso traslada
cajas de medicamentos para su pueblo
de vuelta en la pista de la comunidad
agro sarayaku la atiende una emergencia
sanitaria
este joven perdió la visión a causa de
una fiebre intensa son la única
ambulancia aérea de más de 135.000
hectáreas
los niños no entienden de emergencias y
pueden hacer las aves de los cielos
amazónicos
se consideran descendientes el jaguar
que aseguran que un día también
defenderán su cosmovisión elevándose por
su futuro